[Music]
on this Sunday night rolling out the
benefit package federal emergency money
who qualifies who doesn't is it safe to
remove residents out of care homes
Britain's prime minister in hospital
after testing positive for Cova nineteen
plus a rare appearance from royalty in
self-isolation if we remain united and
resolute then we would overcome it
the Queen's message to the world
global national with Bob and Gil
good evening and thank you for joining
us these are uncertain times but for
tens of thousands of Canadians whose
livelihoods have been affected by the
Cova 19 crisis there is some relief
coming the application process for the
Canada emergency relief benefit begins
tomorrow it should ease the financial
strain as we wait for life to get back
to normal and that could take months you
only have to look at the latest rise in
cases to see we are not out of the woods
there are more than 15,000 confirmed
cases of Cova 19 across Canada about
half are in Quebec more than 79 hundred
cases there that province reported its
biggest single-day rise in cases 947
another 4,000 are in Ontario which
jumped by more than 400 cases overnight
Alberta has confirmed more than 1,100
infections and BC has at least 1200 four
provinces Saskatchewan Manitoba Nova
Scotia and Newfoundland and Labrador are
all reporting more than 200 cases each
nearly 300 people have died from the
illness but at least 3,000 people have
recovered millions of Canadians have
been seriously impacted by the Cova 19
pandemic weather they've been laid off
or have to stop working federal
government begins accepting applications
for the CRB tomorrow David a conjoins us
now to break down who this will help and
why hundreds of thousands won't qualify
David Robin the applications for the
Canada emergency response benefit opens
up Monday morning at 6 a.m. Eastern and
the government expects 3 million
Canadians will apply in the next 7 days
alone the CRB is a flat-rate benefit of
$500 a week to be eligible it doesn't
matter how much you may but you must
have made at least $5,000 in income over
the last 12 months you must have lost
all your employment income for 14
consecutive days anytime after March
15th and you have to be an employee
self-employed or a contract worker the
CRB will also replace employment
insurance for the 2.1 million Canadians
who applied for AI
after March 15th and for those Canadians
no matter how much money you might have
qualified for under III you will
automatically get five hundred dollars a
week the flat rate no need to reapply
for millions the CRB will mean a raise
but for many it may mean a pay cut from
the maximum EEI benefit of five hundred
and seventy three dollars a week down to
that flat rate of five hundred dollars a
week if you choose to direct deposit you
will get a first payment within three to
five days if you choose to receive your
benefit by mail you'll get money within
the next ten days
but hundreds of thousands will not
qualify for the CRB including those who
had applied for or were receiving e aí
before March 15th including those whose
AI benefits are expiring
you will stay in the EEI program those
still working but working only a few
hours a week
any earned income disqualifies you from
the entire $500 a week CRB college and
university students who have had summer
job offers cancelled will not get the
CRB prime minister justin trudeau said
sunday ottawa plans to help students
soon this is an issue that we are very
very aware of from modifications to the
Canada summer job program to looking at
direct support for students we know that
we need to do more for young people as
they come out of university in the
meantime the government is ready to pay
out the GST rebate on Thursday and this
rebate has been doubled to $400 per
person or $600 per couple you can get
information on that payout plus the CRB
at Canada dot see a Robin David another
issue is facemasks than this battle
between the White House and Ottawa over
the presidential order not to send the
crucial n95 mask to Canada how did the
Prime Minister respond to that issue
today and what was his tone well Trudeau
is still looking for a negotiated
resolution but Trump's move has angered
a whole lot of people in Canada
including the premier of Newfoundland
and Labrador that in a time of crisis
you don't stop being human in 2001 our
province step
in the biggest way possible when the
United States was in crisis after the
terrorist attacks in New York
Newfoundland and Labrador accepted with
open arms thousands of people from
around the world so today to say that I
am infuriated with the recent actions of
President Trump of the United States is
an understatement
I cannot believe for a second in a time
of crisis the president Trump would even
think about banning key medical supplies
to Canada now Trudeau and Trump by the
way have not yet talked about this
they're still leaving it up to their
officials for now Robin David akin in
Ottawa thanks David one of the biggest
areas of concern in Quebec a quarter of
all nursing homes in the province have
confirmed cases of kovin 19 a fitting
home for so many families with loved
ones in long-term care and as imagine
della wiki reports they're weighing
whether it's safer to get them out
Timothy Pereira placed his aging aunt in
a Montreal nursing home just last week
the 72 year old suffers from severe
disabilities and needs professional care
but her residence has a Koba 19 outbreak
it's really tough to imagine that maybe
the decision that I made to bring her
there could end up with her dying
doctors also told Pereira his aunt would
likely get better emergency care at home
the doctor actually told me to come and
pick her up and bring her home and that
she would be in a better situation and I
thought that was really disturbing
Pereira's situation is becoming a
worrying all too familiar refrain in
Quebec at staggering one-quarter of all
of Quebec sinner Seng homes have koban
19 outbreaks 60% of Quebec 94 Ovid 19
related deaths occurred in seniors
residences the government has adopted
stricter measures like banning visitors
but they're also changing policy quickly
on Thursday Quebec public health
director said seniors were too
vulnerable if they left nursing homes
and went home Friday the government
flip-flop so we did that we discussed it
very quickly yesterday and we decided
this is the way to go given the dire
situation in seniors residences some
experts say going
home is the best option if you have a
healthy senior right now who's in a
residence I do strongly encourage people
to go get them find somewhere where it's
gonna be a little bit safer and where
they can have a bit more attention paid
to them many don't have that choice
both Rennie Menards parents are in homes
she's worried she won't see them again
she is locked up in there she can't even
go out for a walk we can't take her home
because there are cases in the building
so we can't take your home so we're very
worried and with deaths rising each day
families are terrified their loved one
could be next
Amanda John the wiki Global News
Montreal another resident at a care home
in Ontario the site of an outbreak has
died the total number of deaths is now
23 at Pine Crest nursing home in
Bobcaygeon at least 24 staff members at
the facility have also tested positive
for kovat 19 the choral princess with
100 Canadians on board has docked in
Florida but they haven't been allowed to
get off the cruise ship while others
have there are cases of Kovan 19 on the
boat but the cruise line insists none of
the Canadians has this deadly virus
here's Jennifer Johnson after weeks at
sea the coral princess is now docked to
Miami its voyage a vacation that became
a nightmare two passengers dying on
board a third in hospital as others
required stretchers to be carried off
sick with cope in 19 Gary Lyon and his
wife Sue are from Toronto they planned
the trip to celebrate their 40th wedding
anniversary on the cruise but they are
still stranded we've been in our cabin
since Tuesday we've had meals brought to
us to our door that kind of dropped them
and run I think what's frustrating right
now today we were just not getting any
update so we're not sure what's
happening for the Canadian their voyage
began exactly one month ago in Chile and
there was no talk of Kovan 19 there it
was supposed to end two weeks ago in
Argentina but the ship was forced to
sail for weeks as country after country
refused an entry on board over 1,000
passengers and close to 900 crew members
cut off and isolated as the Cova 19
pandemic took over the world
Miami's mayor finally offered a lifeline
it's unfortunate that on the on the way
here to 2 pi
she was died and so for me it was okay
we got to take some people off that are
serious condition we need to save some
lives as other cruises around the world
return to ports and future ones never
departed more passengers aboard the
Coral Princess became ill Grace and
Peter Nam both tested positive for the
virus
health officials will eventually allow
all those who are fit to fly home to
leave through a closed off terminal at
Miami International Airport fully masked
the sick are being sent to already
crowded local hospitals but for now
Canadian travelers still don't know when
they'll be flown out or through what
airport just set upon their return home
they face 14 days in mandatory self
isolation we're happy to follow them we
just need to be in Canada to follow them
like so many others anxious to be ending
a vacation they'll just be happy to
survive Jennifer Johnson Global News in
New York the death toll continues to
climb there have been more than 4,200
deaths but there is some hope the spread
is slowing the state recorded a slight
dip in fatalities today but Governor
Andrew Cuomo says it's too early to tell
whether the pandemic has reached its
peak there were 594 deaths in the last
24 hours
down from 630 fatalities yesterday the
number of ICU admissions is also down
British Prime Minister Boris Johnson has
been admitted to hospital as a
precaution he continues to show symptoms
of kovat 19 since testing positive ten
days ago
the UK has suffered a record single day
spike in deadly cases of kovin 19 more
than 700 people died in the last 24
hours
and despite lockdown warnings people are
venturing out into parks and socialising
police are being forced to tell people
to get back inside nearly five thousand
people have died from Cova 19 in the UK
and there are more than 48,000 confirmed
cases Queen Elisabeth delivered a rare
national address today as cases of Cova
19th surge she appealed to Britons to
unite to remain disciplined and to stay
home described
this moment in time as one that will
define the present and the future I'm
speaking to you at what I know is an
increasingly challenging time together
we are tackling this disease and I want
to reassure you that if we remain united
and resolute then we will overcome it
while we have faced challenges before
this one is different this time we join
with all nations across the globe in a
common endeavor the Queen adds better
days are to come this is only the fifth
time the Queen has delivered a special
televised address in her 68 year royal
reign apart from her Christmas messages
the first happened at the beginning of
the Gulf War in 1991 the second was
after the death of Princess Diana in
1997 the Queen spoke again upon the
death of her mother in 2002 and for her
Diamond Jubilee in 2012 coming up a
warning from researchers about rushing a
vaccine
there's a big push around the world to
find a vaccine but there are fears a
rush solution could bring on
side-effects and provide fuel for
anti-vaxxers crystal go man singh breaks
down the complexity of creating a new
vaccine billions of people are locked in
their homes one of the few rudimentary
protections we have against a virus
that's infecting and killing people at a
record pace it's this microscopic
ball-like structure with its spikes that
scientists are racing to decipher and
defeat no the virus actually ducts and
in fuses with the membrane under coats
and then delivers its payload and it's
that whole lifecycle that we understand
Jonathon Heaney is a Canadian scientists
working at Cambridge University his team
is one of more than 40 registered with
the World Health Organization pursuing a
vaccine for kovat 19 even though we
still know very little about the disease
have a very very spotted history in fact
it's very very difficult to get an
effective vaccine for coronaviruses SARS
and MERS are in the same viral family
they don't have vaccines yet either a
paper published in the Official Journal
of the National Academy of Sciences
highlighted past pitfalls that caused
the immune system to backfire one of the
side effects antibody dependent
enhancement essentially the body makes
it easier for the virus to invade
officials in Ottawa said safety is the
priority we don't want to be vaccinating
people and making it worse and there are
a number of adverse outcomes that can
happen if you move too quickly any
severe safety issues will immediately
trigger a review of that trial but in
the race to find a vaccine regular drug
testing steps are being combined and
work is progressing faster than ever
vaccines in general are big moneymakers
a vaccine during a pandemic
would be huge Heaney doesn't want
anything overlooked in the rush to get a
product to market which could feed the
anti-vaxxer is that will get these nasty
side effects and the public will get the
impression that these are dangerous
vaccines as death tolls rise people may
become more accepting of risks
associated with vaccines but scientists
like Heaney are calling for more
worldwide collaboration and cautioning
time is a necessity to get it right
crystal the Manson Global News London
still ahead parenting postponed the
impact of Cova 19 on fertility
treatments
the pandemic has forced all of us to put
our lives on hold for some Canadians
that includes the dream of having
children fertility treatments have been
postponed at clinics across the country
and as Karen Lieberman explains that's
causing more uncertainty for couples
hoping to become parents March in every
day four year old Isabella asks her
mother when she's getting a baby brother
or sister
our daughter is constantly drawing
pictures of you know babies and mommy's
tummy so she's so excited about having a
sibling a month ago the Millar chicks of
Oshawa Ontario had hoped they were one
step closer to making that happen
we've been working at that now for a
couple of years the journey has been a
long one three rounds of in-vitro
fertilization to conceive their daughter
a fourth round for a second child was
unsuccessful this year is when we said
you know what let's give it our last go
and we'll just do a fifth round a final
round and if we get lucky that's great
finally the news they've been waiting
for a viable embryo ellen:oh was ready
to transfer right away then the corona
virus pandemic put everything including
fertility treatments on hold you have
this moment where you're so excited you
finally got that embryo because any
fertility process is just about waiting
and waiting and waiting and then we have
to wait some more fertility clinics
across the country shut down after the
Canadian fertility and enter ology
society advised they suspend all
diagnostic and elective procedures and
surgeries and postpone new cycle starts
other than for fertility preservation
related to cancer treatment this affects
patients in the midst of or about to
start treatments such as in vitro
fertilization intrauterine insemination
and frozen embryo transfer our clinic
geo fertility is fully physically closed
all the ten positions however are still
working actively talking to patients via
telephone consultations for couples
struggling with infertility the process
is already emotional and uncertain
sherry Cohen who conceived her son with
the use of an egg donor after four
miscarriages is hoping to help there is
this entire universe of women out there
who were lonely scared and afraid before
but now with the onset of covin 19 they
might have been in the middle of a cycle
they might have been gearing up with a
drug protocol and now all of a sudden
stopped out in their tracks cohen holds
virtual warrior infertility circles a
way of bringing women together online
and ensuring they feel supported
infertility is a brutal journey for
anyone to have to go through the best of
times and sadly it strikes one in five
of us Ellen and Millar chick is anxious
to implant her one last embryo to find
out whether Isabella will get that
sibling she longs for and a lot of women
out there who have fertility issues time
is always the huge concern but with no
indication of how long fertility clinics
will remain closed the couple will have
to wait to grow their family Karen Lee
Berman Global News Toronto up next the
women looting Canada's fight against the
kovat 19 pandemic
leaders of all kinds are playing a huge
role in the response to Cova 19 and in
Canada many of the key leaders are
doctors who happen to be women that's
inspiring people across the country to
find ways to honor these public health
heroes based on the information
available cases up theirs Teresa Tam
Canada's public health officer and
there's a rationale for why we body
Henry DC's medical officer of health
this is not an overreaction Deena head
shot in charge of the health of
Albertans their doctors who deliver the
disconcerting details about a virus
that's taking lives and they're all
women leading the charge that inspired a
Calgary artist and an entrepreneur to
put their faces on t-shirts to raise
money for food banks they swiftly sold
out these are women who are in science
and it's about them being able to
exercise their leadership in a in a time
where we need that sort of that real
combination of both data and science but
also this caring compassion that they
seem to manage to to tie together to
Vancouver roommates
Amy Shire and Vicki Henderson wrote a
song devoted to B C's medical officer of
health they're also qualified and
competent and calm and they're giving
you real information and factual
information so by way of update in
Toronto that city's Public Health
Officer is being honored in a unique way
with a tutor account for the scarves she
wears daily proving their style and
substance how many scarves do you have
I'm not sure these women certainly
didn't have a following weeks ago now we
know their names and we know they are we
can recognize that yeah you have nice
eyes and we just learned another
front-and-center not looking for stardom
but a solution to this crisis and that
is global national I'm Robin Gill the
NHL season was suspended this year due
to the Cova 19 pandemic but that didn't
stop the go to national anthem singer
for Canucks games from belting out o
Canada last night singer mark Donnelly
did his part to keep spirits high
lending his voice to Vancouver's nightly
cheer for health care workers and we
leave you tonight with some of that
performance thank you for watching have
a good night
[Music]
Oh Canada we stand on guard for thee
[Music]